[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
severance episode eight what's for
dinner this again was directed by ben
stiller and written by chris black okay
before we get into that crazy
cliffhanger i mean i haven't seen that
wild of a cliffhanger in a long time
that you're probably going nuts right
now wanting the finale uh
i mean i feel like my heart is in my
throat right now it was so so intense
and you're probably feeling the same way
but before we get to all that craziness
let's start here where we actually get
to see irv's audi for the first time
there's a lot of stuff going on here so
we first see him sitting on the bench
outside which almost looks identical to
where we saw devin meeting the senator
for the first time and his wife gabby
outside talking to her and realizing
things are off it looks like that
similar town and we see he's staying at
lenoir lake apartments and what's
interesting as well two things i noticed
when he's sitting on this bench is he's
looking up at a hawk flying over him
looks exactly like the hawks will see in
the care animation when hele completes
her quota for the team and also what's
interesting is the church that is near
irv that he's looking at looks exactly
like the church mini model that later in
the episode harmony will destroy in her
shrine so that's a lot of stuff i feel
like that they're just hinting at right
there now what is really cool about this
with irv is that they're showing you he
is literally painting with this black
paint which is now explaining what the
black goo he was seeing is he is
painting all these pictures of the
testing floor that we'll see later in
the episode with miss casey where she
ends up going and what's interesting is
he's drinking coffee he's playing ace of
spades really loud to stay awake and do
this so it makes sense why he's
exhausted at lumen when he goes there
and it makes sense why he's then having
these visions and kind of hallucinating
like to the point where someone who
doesn't get sleep at all this guy does
not sleep so we'll go back to the stuff
with irv in a second when we get to the
end of the episode with that and with
his audi but i really want to hear you
guys series on why he's painting these
paintings what is going on does he have
some you know connection to lumen on the
outside i really want to know now
there's always some great humorous lines
in the show now another one that was
amazing here for me is we see that helly
you know she's playing catch up to
everybody else to hit quota for these
numbers and irv says mark don't laugh i
think it might be helpful for us to
stand behind her and chant her name i
was dead at this line this is like when
they make the humorous moments of the
irv like this is him at his best just
saying stuff so awkward like this i
laughed so hard and you know when heli
hits this 100 we get this very eerie
cure eager animation i love all the
eerie stuff with kirigan again reminding
me of westworld so much just this person
in power you want to know more about
what's really happening here and it was
so creepy when he just says i love you
in the animation to helly very strange
like i said you see those hawks that
look just like the one that erv saw but
we see she hits the quota and then you
know harmony is telling milcek she wants
an end of the quarter wellness session
for mark and you see when she talks to
mark you know she's even suggesting to
him to be the one who stays for the
waffle party not dylan so there was some
part of her that wanted her there and i
think she had bad intentions with mark
whatever they be and want him in that
situation but we're also seeing again
harmony is gonna watch this wellness
session with miss casey and mark knowing
now that miss casey is gemma here it's
so fascinating watching the scene but
knowing that also harmony's watching
that the difference between her and
milchik watching this moment is that
milchik's like look they don't remember
each other that's a good sign but she
sees through that that there is some
connection they're having that's almost
subconscious like that they have the
same connection they would outside of
work that affection she has for him you
see in this scene and that makes me
think that's the reason harmony sent you
know miss casey to the testing floor and
back down there i'm gonna get more into
the testing floor stuff in a second but
this scene really worked for me the
wellness scene because it works so well
with the music now knowing what we know
again that miss casey is his wife in
real life that he thinks is dead and i
love the line where she's like i really
like being in the office with you all
that day my life has been 107 hours long
most of it has been these half hour
sessions my favorite time was the eight
hours i spent in your department it's
the longest i've ever been awake so i
think that obviously they staged her
death her outing in the real life that
she's not really having an audi life out
there that she's only now been in lumen
since then and that she's only
experiencing her severed part like she's
definitely extremely severed and they
had said she's part-time and i think her
other time is whatever in this testing
floor and you see later when she's
brought to testing for by milcheck she
asked him do you know if i'm happy up
there and he's like of course you do all
sorts of wonderful things and to me
again that's just [ __ ] coming out of
milchik's mouth and that again she's not
even having a life outside of lumen
because they have to frame her death so
i think she just gets shut down or
something it's a different situation
than everyone in mdr that a person like
gemma is experiencing so what's
interesting though is you see with
milchik you know he in this episode is
really had it now with harmony and going
against the book with lumen and i think
you know they're getting hints of that
with just his facial expressions but why
would make sense he would rat harmony
out and it would get her fired in this
episode and it's important too to
realize when harmony sent miss casey
down to the testing floor it wasn't the
first time she said take her back down
to the testing floor so again i think
that's where kind of her main base is
when she's not awake as she says so now
we get the egg bar social before the
waffle party and the egg bar social just
another great silly thing like they did
with the music dance experience last
episode just if anyone could comment
below what do you think the music that
was playing we saw on the list from last
episode what was playing during the egg
bar social we heard two songs i think
i'd love to see if you guys can pick out
which ones you think they were and i
love to as just four people at this
social that's one of the funny great
things about this show it's not like
this packed office so we don't at first
see what dylan requested in his box he
was given we see later on that it's just
the glass cube of the mdr photo they
took together showing that uni they have
that bond right this is this team
rebellious effort and again it just
serves more to my theory that dylan's
not gonna make it out of this season
it's a great piece to have him put there
and going out for the team i think that
just confirmed it for me and also
confirmed it to me here when helly says
i can stay back dylan don't you want to
see your kid and he's like what we're
doing tonight is just the first step but
again lines like this with heli saying
that to him just confirms this is it for
dylan and the ironic thing about all
this is that really to me dylan was the
one that would have been the one to make
the most sense that they couldn't see
that because they don't know how their
lives are outside but we can see as the
audience that i think this is all going
to go wrong next episode that if we see
the situations they're in right mark is
with miss selvik the worst thing marx
audies could have done is bring
misselvik to this party so when he snaps
back into place and his innie is in his
audi realizing what's happening you know
right away ms selva's gonna get what's
going on that something's up that he got
switched on then irving i believe is
gonna just freak out because he's gonna
see
the paint and it's gonna trigger his
episodes with the black goo and you got
ace of spades blasting so i just think
everything's just gonna just collapse or
something and i think obviously helly
you know she hints in this episode again
that she jokingly says she's an [ __ ]
on the outside so we see she's at a
champagne party and i don't think it's
at the kier egan family gala yet we're
gonna see that next episode but i don't
think timing wise that it would have
started yet because we're just seeing
they're setting it up outside when
mark's leaving but i do think she's with
people that are bad people so even if
she comes the other heli she's probably
gonna panic being around people that
have a different you know belief than
her but they agree with her audi so
they're gonna know something's up and
she's gonna be telling the wrong type of
people you want to tell this stuff so
again that's why i think dylan you know
probably was the most normal situation
with his son and would have gone to
somebody like authorities so we see the
board again found out about heli
attempting suicide and that they found
out about her even just visiting mark's
sisters they say so it's great because
she goes is the board even there she
flips out and the eerie voice from the
board's like yes who you know a lot of
people think is keir egan just extended
through his life somehow i love this
this was just great stuff it was creepy
i love seeing pattiar catches goal full
just pissed off mode in this episode and
just the death stare she gives mailchick
when he hands her stuff to him for her
to leave was great and then a great line
which is the title episode here is when
herb's leaving for the day he said okay
kids let's find out what's for dinner
and then you get this like meta joke
going on between helly and mark saying
like you know what if we're a couple on
the outside and i think they knew that
was going to be a theory when they
filmed this that that would be a popular
theory and they can kind of make a joke
about it and we know that's not the case
obviously but they get to kiss because
there is a connection between the any
heli any any mark not the outside
versions but the inside yes so where
stuff gets just i did not expect it like
to happen where we get full-on horror
now was the waffle party at kier egan's
house with dylan and he you know eating
this waffle the plate says go now to the
founder's bed he puts on the mask and
then literally something out of an ari
aster horror film starts happening the
music sounds straight out of one of
those films and the masks look like
they're from mid-summer it's just so
eerie and creepy i loved it let me see
that jester mask looks just like it the
one that was in harmony shrine for the
eagan and also you know one of the masks
kind of looked like it might be harmony
which is interesting and it's just crazy
at the same moment she's destroying that
shrine but we see that at the party here
for ricken's book you see that mark
tells ms selva he's thinking about
quitting lumen so she actually is happy
about this relief now because she just
got fired from there and i think she has
some other plan to use someone like mark
who is severed for her wants and
whatever her plan would be maybe to go
now against lumen i'm not sure there's a
lot that could happen here with harmony
now being fired it's a total curveball
and wild card but i still think she'll
plead her case to the board about what
exactly is going on with people that are
reintegrating and i'm talking about
incredible tension and suspense at the
end of this episode we see that dylan is
trying to turn off these two switches we
know it's a two-man job which created so
much suspense but also when he's
figuring out the system we're getting
stuff thrown at us like we see the
system functions that are there like
beehive branch transfer clean slate
which is interesting so they have the
power to probably just clean someone's
total brain whatever side it is maybe
the severed side just really scary and
lullaby too so maybe power to put
someone to sleep if they want and again
getting the first glimpse of helly audi
just in public was crazy everyone's
about to turn on that intensity the
music playing beneath it was just
masterful and
really for me it showed too this whole
episode was that type of pen ultimate
episode sometimes the penultimate
episode in shows is the crazy episode
where crazy stuff happens that wasn't
the case here this was the episode that
is setting up for a wild finale and it
was such a masterful example of a build
up suspense type pen ultimate episode
for a great finale this does it
perfectly so for that alone i'm giving
this one a 9.7 it really is a master
class intention suspense ben still is
showing with his directing he has really
that hitchcock level of building that
tension and suspense and mystery and
getting you just your like heart is
racing i feel like just if you came to
my review from watching episode your
heart is still pounding so i feel that i
think that's just success all together
and i'm really excited i don't see how
this finale can't be amazing like the
what they left it off on i feel like
we're all just now jonesing for the
finale so please make sure to leave your
theories down below what you thought of
this episode and please subscribe so you
don't miss my review of the finale but
definitely be reviewing it please follow
me at st varley show on twitter
instagram tick tock for more of me and
i'll see you next time